so my next guest very excited to have
him here my
former boss good friend of mine someone
i've talked to through this whole
quarantine
please welcome cal pen what's up moses
storm
how are you you're writing this out in
new york every day
that i facetime you i've been trying to
convince you to get out of new york
yeah well now it now it's fine you were
right
for you know what two and a half months
now new york is
absolutely crushing it in numbers it's
not fine i just want to be clear and for
everybody watching who's like oh we
should just go
to new york is still not fine but yeah
it's better than ever to come there and
should go clubbing
is what i heard right that's the message
we'll put out cal pen
says covet is a hoax will be the
clickbait article in fact
if anything i just want everybody from
the rest of the country
to please not come to new york new
jersey or connecticut
like please don't come here we worked
very hard without you
to get this down you went and [ __ ] up
your own states and now that's on you
so please don't come here you gotta let
not all of california but la new york we
have to switch
la is terrible right now because they
just keep going
up it's so sad it's more embarrassing
now because it's supposed to be people
that are like hyper liberal over
cautious i don't give my kid any gluten
or sunlight because that's what those
people are telling
but there's so there's that right but
then the more obvious
the more obvious thing that confuses me
about la
is you don't interact with humans i
lived in l.a for 12 years
you're in your car all the time or
you're in your apartment
people rarely walk how are you guys
spreading this
because they understand hotter in l.a so
people cannot help but smash each other
that's fair that's true
like you're 100 yeah you're garbage
you're used to having as a
performer and i see a lot of down time
so you can just kind of shift into like
oh yeah this is a time where i'm working
or i just got
cancelled for something 2003.
but uh so i want to know have you picked
up any hobbies
or skills that have nothing to do with
your career something that takes your
mind completely off it that maybe are
not going to benefit you at all it's not
like i'm going to learn meisner
technique
uh yeah i i mean
yeah keeping in mind i know the answer
to this question already
from our facetime call last week
is it the cookie any purchases you have
made on
amazon anything that maybe
considered oh wait we oh no he's going
to look for it you're talking about my
puppet
oh yes let me get it you know him you
love him
worked in the white house at one point
puppet let me get this [ __ ] puppet
hold on this
is um oh yeah this is where
oh my god okay this is a purchase i told
him not to do
right before he was making it he was
three beers deep
he'd already purchased uh several wigs
for sketch characters
yeah so and when you said when you said
um when you said have i have i've been
working on anything or purchasing
purchased anything that has
nothing to do with our career i i
you know he he quickly popped into my
mind and i thought well that does sort
of have something to do with our careers
because we're actors
oh no what's up hey guys he's not here
that's a meltdown that's the symptom oh
god
he's a [ __ ] moses storm [ __ ]
moses storm
i mean it's pretty solid character just
for the record
you are the only person friend or
otherwise
who is remotely amused by that's not
true
uh slosh was very amused by him daniel
was was also musical because a puppet is
such a big commitment like
if jeff dunham ran for office right it
would still be like oh the puppet guy
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's such a clear
shift
yeah oh the puppet guy uh-huh yeah yeah
yeah forget everything you've done in
your career you're not the puppet guy
it's so that's maybe the like you know
when you're
when you're tell me if you're the same i
assume the answer is yes but like
you know that that that cliche of like
oh uh
i want to be an actor or comedian or
really any art
insert any artist versus like i have to
do this
like there's a part of my brain and soul
that
needs to express myself this way or tell
stories or whatever it is
that like that's the one thing that i
think
not being able to do is where you end up
buying a puppet on amazon for 10 bucks
right because it's like where where am i
getting that outlet
and it was and this started like that
puppet's been super handy for a lot of
my friends and
cousins who have kids where it's like
hey story time
but then that [ __ ] gets old right and
you're like i have nothing
yeah which is in normal circumstances
really just unfortunate and weird so
we're going to put your gofundme
up if you guys want to donate it's
really having a full-on meltdown
kalpan the puppet guy and not the
respected actor and former white house
employee
and then um i think i think just
speaking about
progressiveness yeah we're at a point
uh industry-wise it's something that you
could speak on
uh where the industry is getting a lot
more progressive with the with the
movements and the the peaceful process
have been going on
where it's taken effect on the industry
where now actors are stepping down from
voice over roles that are
white actors playing people of color
because i think what you were telling me
is that early in your career when you
were coming up there
wasn't the option i mean things are not
even close to what they should be now as
far as
inclusion and people of color getting
the jobs that they deserve
but you didn't even have the discussion
around the time that you were coming up
it was just like here's this character
do you want a career
do this yeah there was a project i did
that that
required an accent and i i took it uh
and i did some research on what the
accent would sound like and
then i get an email from the producers
it's like hey here's the dialect coach
you're going to to make sure that you
can learn the accent i show up to this
office and it's this
old white woman who's teaching me how to
do an indian accent
yeah i i wish you know what i wonder if
i still have the tape somewhere
but it was doing it and then she doing
like actually it's like this well she
would do it first
white people but but at the time
the thing that's interesting now when i
look at like you know how
how people seem to be realizing that
this is not a good idea
is that i was obviously very bothered by
it at the time
but i also just felt exhausted by it
where again it's like
oh i thought maybe i was going to a
dialect coach the same way that you do
in drama school because
you have a role coming up and maybe you
mumble
yeah and i realized very quickly i'm
like i don't have the luxury of
you mumble because they just want this
accent the way that they want it
right so it's like that's the constant
thing that that i think sometimes is
missed in these conversations
about identity which is the bottom line
is we all want really great storytelling
we want compelling storytelling
you know network tv is very slow to
catch up to this a lot of the
the paid and streaming services
especially especially netflix and amazon
have been very forward thinking about
diverse casting
and it's worked for them i think because
audiences are sick of seeing
the same cookie-cutter type of shows so
that doesn't even necessarily mean
diversity at face value and hopefully
it's not just diversity of face value
it's like
characters that come from totally
different walks of life interacting in
ways that we haven't seen before
in brutally honest ways ways that make
the storytelling more interesting and
more lively and
and just make us better like what do you
want out of tv what do you want out of
your
out of your experience you want to feel
something you want to laugh you want to
you know it's all of that that i think
is just better served
when you have casting that's that that
reflects our experiences
well that's what i i really got to see
firsthand on
on the show that i worked out that with
you at your show
um where it was like okay yeah it's a
diverse show and outside of all the
clickbait
articles and like pitching the show like
it's the most diverse cast it's
immigrants with the exception of me who
looks like the son of gavin newsom
uh when you're on set all those articles
go away
and it just becomes those actors are
just the best people for this job
yeah it has nothing to do with their
backgrounds born in ethiopia it's like
no that's just a funny good actor
and we should give more opportunities
for those people to shine
if you do it right i think that's what
you end up with right
if you uh you know there are
i have several friends who in the last
couple years
uh have you know you'll get like
you'll have like a passing comment from
one of your one of your white actor
friends like i auditioned for that movie
i didn't get it because i'm white i'm
like oh yeah i can relate
oh but you still own everything you
still control all of everything
right sorry so my first reaction is i
can relate from the last
15 years of my career i get it like yeah
no that's not fair like
that means that like i'm just gonna have
to i'm just gonna
to try harder you're gonna have to try
to find
out work as hard you didn't work as hard
you felt like let me have my dad call
the studio
right crying harder so
there was a lot of raytheon yeah there
are some uh what do what if people in
politics say
they have such fun uh and by fun i mean
insufferable
ways of describing things uh oh those
are the industries going through some
growing pains
like no the [ __ ] sucks for a lot of
people um but
that's part of i think what ultimately
will make better
art and storytelling perhaps yes more
people are represented